يخبرني الكثير من الناس أنه بالتأكيد
معجزة أنه هدية من الله
وأنه من المفترض أن يفعل شيئًا مجنونًا في هذا
العالم ، يبلغ عمر ريلاند درينان الآن خمسة أشهر ،
إنه أمر
سريالي للغاية ، لكن في ستة أشهر
في معدة والدته سامانثا ، فإن
الاحتمالات  لم يكن في مصلحته جيدًا أبريل ،
اكتشفنا أن لدينا رايلان مصابًا بورم
مسخي في القلب
وهو ورم ينمو في قلبه ،
حالته هي حالة لا يراها الأطباء في
كثير من الأحيان ، فهي نادرة بشكل لا يصدق بشكل
عام ، فهم فقط مثل واحد في  أربعون
ألف ولادة
ثم إنجابها في هذا
الموقع من القلب هو أمر أقل شيوعًا
والأكثر ندرة هو الإزالة الناجحة لهذا
الورم ، حيث تم إجراء العملية
عدة مرات فقط في جميع أنحاء العالم وكانت ناجحة
بمجرد أن كانت الاحتمالات
ضدنا تمامًا
وكنا كذلك  على ثقة من أننا قمنا بتجميع
الفريق المناسب بعد مناقشة
ووزن الخيارات التي يموت بها الجنين بشكل أساسي يعاني من
قصور في القلب ،
وأعتقد أن الأطباء وسامانثا وافقوا على أن
الجراحة كانت  في السابع من مايو ، أجرينا
عملية جراحية للجنين ، واستغرق الأمر أربع ساعات ،
وقام الدكتور نجم بما يمكن أن يفعله بطفل
بعد الولادة ، وقام
بقطع أأ باتجاه منتصف الصدر
لفتح القفص الصدري لفضح
قلب هذا الطفل الصغير.
ساعد في تقشير الورم من القلب
أشياء مدهشة جدًا وكان
نجاحًا لحسن الحظ رايلان الصغير
داخل رحم
الأم وتعافت الأم بشكل جميل
للمرة الثانية فقط في التاريخ ، بعض
الممرضات اللائي كن في غرفتي أخبرنني
بذلك  لقد بكوا وما زالوا يبكون ويبكون
لمجرد
أنه كان أكثر الأشياء جنونًا التي
مروا بها على الإطلاق بعد الإزالة ،
تم وضع ريان في معدة والدته ليخبز
لمدة 10 أسابيع ثم قرر الخروج
مبكرًا في 36 أسبوعًا  وثلاثة
أيام دخل إلى العالم
إلى عالم كان قد استثمره بالفعل
دافئًا هنا ، إنه أمر مثير
للارتياح ، إنه أمر لا يصدق ، وسرعان
ما ستخبره بقصته البطولية ذات
يوم سيسأل مثل ما هذا الجنون  لقد
قمت بتلطيخ صدري وسأخبرهم أنك مررت بشيء
مجنون
لا يستطيع أي طفل أن يقول إنه مرّ
بتغطية الأخبار في أخبار كليفلاند نادين أبو زادة
5.